And I said this was the best answer, but don't worry if you put something different.
Let's see what Dr. Fara has to say.
[Patricia Fara] There is one thing that everybody knows about Isaac Newton--
that he sat beneath an apple tree and had a flash of inspiration.
We don't know, and I don't think we can ever know, whether it really happened.
What he said was that he was sitting in his garden, in his orchard
where he'd had to retreat from Cambridge because of the plague,
so he was sitting in the orchard watching the apples fall around him
and suddenly he thought to himself, why is it that that apple falls to the ground?
Why doesn't it move sideways or upwards?
And is it possible that there is one single force that makes the apple fall to the ground
and makes the moon go 'round the earth and makes the earth go 'round the sun?
And that is allegedly the great "Eurkea" moment, the flash of inspiration,
and that's the significance of the apple.